-Welcome back.
Our next guest
is a talented actress
you know from movies such as
"The King of Staten Island"
and "Assassination Nation."
She currently stars as Lexi in
the hit HBO series "Euphoria."
The season finale airs
this Sunday at 900 p.m.
Let's take a look.
-I need you to pull it way back.
You're too broad.
It's not funny.
-[ Sniffles ]
-Oh, are you crying?
It's a directorial note.
You just take it and move on,
okay?
Hey, I need the light cues
to be 40% faster
and the stagehands
to be 20% faster.
-Copy that.
-Ew!
God, what the --
Did someone die in this dress?
It smells like [bleep]
Ugh!
[Bleep]
I love the theater.
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome to the show
Maude Apatow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hi, Maude!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We are so happy
to have you here.
-Oh, my gosh,
I'm so excited to be here.
-And you genuinely --
Look, it's a fantastic
acting performance,
but you do genuinely
love the theater.
-Of course.
-That was a line that must have
been easy for you to say.
-Yes.
No, Sam and I had a lot of
discussions about it beforehand,
and it was loosely based on me
as a theater child.
-And you were very early
into the theater, yes?
-Yes. So, I started
when I was really young.
I remember I always, like,
really went for it, too.
So, like, my first --
I did, like, a gold-rush day,
and I wanted to look
like a miner.
So I, like,
ripped out my tooth to, like,
look more like a --
-Was it a loose tooth?
-It was not a loose tooth
at all.
-Oh, no!
-It was not ready to go,
and I just ripped it out.
-How old?
What age are we talking about?
-I think I was 9.
-This is way --
-But I was dedicated.
-They say people should not
go method
until they're like 12 or 13.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-What did -- Your parents,
I should note, have both been
guests on this show,
Judd and Leslie.
And what did they --
how did they react
when you took out a tooth for
the purposes of a school play?
-I think my dad was like,
"What is wrong with her?
Oh, no.
We've raised a monster."
But, no, that's -- and then it
just got worse as I got older.
Like, I --
Yeah, I just became a tyrant.
-Yeah.
So, and would you --
Do you think that those who were
in your early school plays
would reflect back
and say that was --
-Of course.
-Yeah, okay, gotcha.
-Yeah, yeah.
No, I got a couple texts
when the show aired, like,
"Triggered."
Like --
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "Oh, no!"
But I remember, like,
senior year of high school,
I was doing a play,
and, like, the pinnacle moment
of the play, this kid, like,
is supposed to slap me
in the face.
-What was the play?
-It was "Cabaret."
-Okay, gotcha.
I was like, these --
I don't know if you should do
"slap in the face" plays
in high school.
-Probably not.
But he, like, did this, like,
goofy slap, and I was so mad.
I was like, "God,
this is ruining the moment.
Like, come on.
Like, slap me for real."
And he's like, "No, no, no,
I don't want to do that."
I'm like,
"You're embarrassing me.
Like, you're
embarrassing yourself.
Just do it."
And he, like,
slapped me really hard
in the show.
So, like, I think
I made him really mad.
-Oh, my God.
-So when we were actually
doing it, yeah.
-He was probably like,
"I don't want to slap
another tooth out."
[ Laughter ]
-But it caught me off guard
how hard he slapped me.
He really went for it
during the show.
-Yeah, oh, my gosh.
-And I was
really happy about it.
-A real commitment.
This is --
You do seem
really happy in this.
So, this is a production of --
Where in high school
are you for "Grease"?
-Oh, no, that's not high school.
-Okay, gotcha.
All right, good.
-That's --
I think I was 9 or 10.
-9 or 10.
This is a production
of "Grease."
And I would just like
to point out, only person
in this photo who seems to know
where the camera is.
[ Laughter ]
-It's an aggressive jazz hand.
-It is a very aggressive
jazz hand.
Well, I'm sure your entire cast
of "Grease"
is very proud of you right now.
-I hope so.
-You and I
have something in common.
We both went to
Northwestern University.
-Yeah.
-Your career took off
a little bit faster than mine,
and you were there
for a couple of years,
and then, you basically --
you know, you didn't
need the rest of it.
-[ Laughs ]
No, I, uh -- I had a great time
at Northwestern.
I left to shoot "Euphoria,"
but --
-That's a good reason.
That's a good reason to go.
-Yeah.
-If I would've left,
it would've been, like,
to go back to my job
as a sub delivery guy.
[ Laughter ]
Did you -- But you want
to clear something up
about your time at Northwestern.
-Okay.
So, my freshman year,
in the dorm bathroom,
there was a bath,
and no one would ever
go in the bath.
-No, of course.
You would never.
-No, no, no.
Like, it was foul.
-It's bad enough
you have to go in the shower.
-Yeah, yeah.
The bath was, like,
covered in, like,
fungus and spores.
And, like, I remember it was
like orange mold sort of.
-Yeah.
-And I was brushing my teeth
one night, and a girl came up
to me, and she's like,
"Heard you've been
going in the bath."
And I was like, "What? No."
I was like,
"That's so weird. What?"
'Cause I hadn't.
And then I went up
to my friend Sydney, I was like,
"It's so funny.
Like, this girl came up to me,
she said that she heard
I was going in the bath,"
and she's like,
"Yeah, I heard that, too."
[ Laughter ]
So, I guess there's a rumor
that I was bathing in, like,
this really disgusting bath,
and I wasn't, so...
[ Laughter ]
-That's good.
So we want to say right now,
on national television...
-It didn't happen.
-...the bath thing
never happened.
-Yes.
-And, also, I mean,
those bathrooms -- like, I mean,
there are a bunch of people.
It would be impossible to take
a bath in a college bathroom
without people
walking in on you.
-Right? Or I was doing it
at like 3:00 a.m.?
-Yeah. I will say, it would be
a very boss move
to just take a bath
in a dorm bathroom
and just have people walk in
and be like, "Hey!"
-Fully sprawled out.
-Yeah.
Like, "Hey, do you need --
do you need the bath?
I can get out."
It's like, "No, we're good."
[ Laughter ]
-That's horrible.
What dorm were you in?
-I was in Willard my first year.
Which dorm were you in?
-I was in Elder.
-Elder, yeah.
Oh, you were the girl
who took the bath!
[ Laughter ]
-Aah!
-I heard that --
This was in the alumni magazine.
Now I'm putting it all together.
I have a lot more questions
about "Euphoria."
We'll be right back
with more from Maude Apatow.